killer cop wayne cousins occasional role
in protecting parliament has alarmed mps
they expect their police guards to be
the most highly vetted
scotland yard admits that when it vetted
cousins it missed suspicions around him
that he had indecently exposed himself
six years ago i believe there are in
other individuals who have got
questionable backgrounds who should be
being looked at
not just in the met right up and down
the country and i think we have missed
that and instead of looking backwards we
should be looking forward and making
sure that those individuals are targeted
now the national police chief's council
said that all officers and staff were
regularly re-vetted some of them each
year but all of them had to report any
change that could affect their clearance
wayne cousins didn't have a criminal
conviction
but did you know that hundreds of
officers do have one
last year sky news revealed that at
least 211 police officers and pcsos in
the uk had criminal convictions
the police service of northern ireland
said 99 of its officers had been
convicted while serving in kent 22
officers had criminal convictions five
of them ranked inspector or above of the
45 uk forces contacted by sky news only
a third replied it means the real number
of convicted officers is likely to be
much higher
when a person applies to the police
service you have a number of checks
which includes your partner your
close family you have to provide details
of their dates of birth where they're
living names
and then once that those checks have
been done that also in addition to that
do checks on your debts whether you've
got any extensive debt and if there are
any flags or any concerns then they'll
come back to you to clarify this or they
may decide not to
go any further with your application
process
cousins was off duty when he confronted
sarah everard on the street he used his
warrant card to convince her he had the
right to arrest her
then he handcuffed her and drove her
away to rape and strangle her
in scotland police said anyone stopped
by a loan officer would be offered
verification allowed to listen in on a
radio call to the control room and be
assured of the officer's credentials
martin brunt sky news